Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcasts for Monday, June 26,
2017 what's going on?
How
Hi are you doing?
How are you doing this fucken
Monday morning is global warming,
making you rough is hot.
Um,
climate change.
Let's give it a nicer name.
So
what are we going to use was a
euphemism, Huh? Photosynthesis.
Jesus Christ. The, the
photosynthesis fucking police.
There's nothing people enjoy more on
the internet other than jerking off to
people sold into the sex industry.
Sex, what do they call it?
A human trafficking is fucking,
um,
correcting somebody.
Jesus fucking Christ,
the amount of gold they give
you have God for fucking bed.
A pasty fucking dope like me
makes a mistake every once,
every fucking five minutes on a podcast.
All of you fucking cunts cannot wait to
go on the Internet and just read me the
riot act like, like you're up for
some sort of fucking award in, in, in,
in the science industry, you know,
whatever the fuck they call it,
the science circuit.
So they always call a radio,
guys say that. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
We are working the circuit.
You mean doing the road? I didn't
realize there was a circuit. Um,
everybody fucking comment at
me. Photosynthesis. You are.
I think you met pollination.
Laughing my ass off.
You know Jesus fucking Christ.
Let me leave and let me
look it up right now. Paul,
the Nation de Duh de Duh Duh Paula nation.
Why is it ever been a ball player named
that pollination is the process by which
pollen is transferred to the female
reproductive organs of a plant,
thereby enabling fertilization to
take place. Like all living organisms,
seed plants ever singer may single major
goal to pass their genetic information
onto. All right, well how the fuck does
it get there? Well, it's pollination.
O I s I said photosynthesis.
All right,
so that's what I thought
photosynthesis was. Okay, here we go.
Photo synthesis.
That doesn't have a good
[inaudible] Paula nation
photo.
Oh
synthesis. I'd say you'd have to
bring them up now. Batting number 22
oh,
that's more like the MMA
fighting out of the red corner.
Hmm.
They can see, I guess what he
would just read the definition
fighting out of the red corner.
The process by which green plants and
some other organisms you sound like
designs that food.
They're writing,
um,
from carbon dioxide to war and water.
The process by which green
plants and some other organisms,
you sunlight to synthesize
foods from carbon dioxide,
carbon dioxide and water.
What does synthesize me?
See,
this is what happens.
Are they using a autotune synthesize,
s y,
s y.
S a sort of synthesize. You know
what I meant? All right. Sin.
Sin, the SIS synthesize. All right.
The combination of ideas to
form a theory or system. Well,
that doesn't sound like the definition.
They were looking for. Synthesis.
Synthesis. Oh, come on. You fucking cunt.
Plural.
Synthesis the formation of a chemical
compound through the combination of a
simple compound of elements.
See Multi you guys that knew
that I used the wrong word.
You couldn't fucking tell
me what all these shipment.
You don't unless you own a lab coat,
right?
Photo synthesis, the process by which
green plants and some of the organism use.
Use Sunlight to synthesize foods
from carbon dioxide and water.
Like digest them. Turn them into something
edible says some con right now, like,
yeah,
shut up. All right, there you
fucking beaker reading cunt.
Fuck you. When you're black
framed glasses. All right.
Least I own my work.
Unlike you in the science industry,
who owns your shit and
what do they use it for?
You're out there trying to feed
plants using sunlight, right?
And all of a sudden they come up
with a new way to send our magic.
Mike says what? I'm starting to
call our missiles, Magic Mike's.
That's what we have in this country. We
got the top of the line fucking missiles.
You know,
like the,
the Mercedes in the Ferrari's
in f one top of the line.
We got the magic mix. We shoot them
into city a only kill the bad people,
right? Then all these terrorists groups,
they like to fucking, uh, the, uh,
who's the guys in the
orange cars this year,
that fucking cars blow up every Goddamn
fucking race. One of the Goddamn drivers,
cause you know what? Fuck you
guys, I'm taking a race off.
I'm going to go drive the Indy 500 he
left Formula One to drive a fucking Indy
five either an Indy car race in America.
The Mclaren Honda is still like the
terrorist group. You know what I mean?
You don't know what the fuck's going
to happen, but we got the magic mix.
Magic bikes, photo synthesis, um,
Paula nation,
whatever you guys got me.
I'm the fucking, what's that
guy? Yachty, the guy, Jada,
you said blow me like a cello or whatever.
I don't think I've ever related to a
rapper more in that moment, you know,
is wide as I am. That's
what it took. You know,
not talking about this
and talking about that.
It's the fact that that poor bastard
thought a cello was a wind instrument.
I was like,
you know what?
This sounds like the kind of person that
I went to summer school with and you
know what?
I bet he has other talents.
Yeah.
Other than being able to memorize all you
fucking cons out there where they were
able to memorize what photosynthesis
was versus pollination.
Can I ask you a question? Seriously. In
all seriousness, where did it get you?
Huh? Other than getting to be
some content at cocktail party,
you know, what are you his social life,
you can talk photosynthesis and fashion.
Um, you know, by the way,
thank you for correcting me.
I don't know how it's
going to affect my life,
but there was just something about the
joy that people took in and correcting me
that uh, I took umbrage with
that. I use that correctly.
Or is that the wrong you word?
You know what?
You know what I like about Twitter
is I don't even have to read anymore.
I'll just say shit that I think is right
and you guys can correct me, right?
I'll learn things.
You guys can feel better about yourselves.
You know that they could say, yeah, it's
a little fucking, what do they call those?
Surf and turf. Little scratch my
back. I scratch your back. I Dunno.
What do you see?
Beyonce sister.
She's got a Gig at the fucking
Hollywood ball. That's pretty what?
A fucking talented family.
You know what I mean?
That's how talented that family is.
Like she can't even get anybody to look
at her at the Thanksgiving table because
they're fucking oldest sister sold out
the rose bowl. You know what I mean?
She's like the fuck up of the family cause
she only sold out the Hollywood bowl.
Honey, honey, honey,
quiet down. Quiet down.
Your sister is talking about what it was
like to be singing bootylicious as the
stealth bomber flew over the stage.
Okay.
Um, was that wrong to do that?
Speaking of uh, pollination,
will this get the beehive after me?
You know what's funny about
all of those fucking groups?
This so up the ass of the artist.
I swear to God she would fucking,
she wouldn't take her God damn shoes
off to run across the street and make a
fucking emergency call and one of
those old telephones back in the day,
let's just say there wasn't cell phones.
If she saw one of you guys
sitting on the side of the road,
she wouldn't give a shit about you.
What's another one?
Who's another one's got a big
following, you know, that was it.
It's the beehive
as a Mariah Carey have one.
You know what I mean?
I don't know what it is.
It's just, I don't know what,
there's something about acting like a
complete asshole and treating people like
shit that just women can't get an up
a certain type of woman. They can,
they can't get enough of it.
What it, why, you know something
I always wanted if,
if more women were like Rhonda Rousey of
the current champion that I don't know
the name of. My apologies. Um,
if more of them took like MMA could
actually beat the fuck out of you,
would they just not walk around being
mean to each other as much? You know, guy,
I think that's the only reason why guys
aren't as mean as women are because
personally speaking anyways,
cause I know that 90% of guys can
beat the shit out of me. Right.
At the very least land.
A couple to my, you know,
and I fucking bruise like the Irishman.
I am, you know, stop the fight, you know,
two punches in. I don't need
that shit. So I try to basically,
you know, mind my ps and qs.
What does that stand for?
How you fucking brainiacs?
Um, what does that stand for?
Let me find out. Like, you know,
and I have to fact check everything so
I don't get fucking and get people up my
ass again.
Mine.
Hm.
Your p's and q's minding
your ps and Qs p and Q.
Origin or is it yeah, it's ps and Qs,
not p and Q. Mind your p's and q's.
You fucking cunt. How do you not to
say that without you fucking cunt.
Okay.
What does mind your p's and q's come from?
This is going to be a very
special educational podcast.
It's just going to be me.
All right.
Okay.
If you've ever been told
him mind your p's and q's,
it might have struck you as
a rather odd thing to do.
That's a nice way of saying
it was annoying. I think
anytime somebody say, hey,
mind your p's and q's, I, my immediate
thought was, who the fuck is this guy
telling me to mind these things?
Uh,
I almost said some eighties comedy
telling me to mind these things. Uh,
the concepts seems reasonable
enough. Behaving, behaving. Well,
not giving offense,
but quite but co quite what the letters
p and Q have to do with this as a little
more mysterious. Why not be in
d o Jesus? Here's something.
Why not be a day?
Can you just fucking get a
whole entry? All right. Yeah,
there's a whole fucking,
this guy's just, you know,
some funny about these fucking
assholes who write for a living.
They just can't get to it.
They feel if they don't take up
a whole fucking page or bill,
maybe there's people out there that enjoy
reading. Maybe it's sad. Okay, I'll, I'll,
you know,
I'll take the ride.
Why not be in d or m and m m
n n or any other combination?
Sadly,
as it often is the case with the more
intriguing terms in the English language,
there is no definitive answer
to the other one. What the fuck.
No one knows what it means.
This last meeting were like to to that,
that Dah the
mean queen and not queen.
What the best possible manners.
Mind your dancing.
Yeah, I dunno. The Oxford dictionary
doesn't even know the answer.
You know it's funny. They don't even
have the fucking answer yet. They still,
they still couldn't. They couldn't
keep their mouth shut. Could they?
I bet somebody else has.
Once somebody at this point see Internet,
somebody's going to take a guess.
All right. What does it mean?
Yeah.
Ever been told to mind your P's and cute
every yes. Yes. That's why I'm here.
Unless you're working on mechanical
printing press at the time,
chances are you are fairly subtly
being told to mind your manners,
but what exactly are your p's and q's?
The short answer is knowing really know
why isn't that why? Why is it that
right there mind your p's and q's.
What does it mean and then boom.
Nobody knows.
Yeah.
What?
What kind of a fucking [inaudible] you
ever been told to mind your p's and q's?
Well, you weren't, you know, writing
press, fucking two paragraphs. This,
you know what to do is,
cause this is delving into the world
of people that like to know shit.
So even when they don't know shit,
they still have to fucking write
three paragraphs on it. Alright,
fuck all of this. Fuck all that.
They've always just frustrating.
Um, anyways, and I am actually being out.
Before I looked up those things before
I remember that you guys corrected me.
You know, maybe you guys
weren't being assholes. Maybe
just trying to help me out.
You know, snakes, I'm
hanging around a socialite,
you know,
socially, as far as I can tell, it's
just a well red gold digging whore,
you know,
like how did you get there?
You've got to be married to
somebody rich if you just want,
if you just pleasant to be around, you
don't really have a fucking job. I mean,
somebody's going to be bring,
bringing home the Bacon, right?
Yeah.
Bringing home the Bacon.
Where did that come from? You
know, I mean, unless you're,
unless you're a farmer, I don't
know a less you, you're working a,
unless you're a board chair.
I was 20 fucking paragraphs later
point is nobody really knows.
Um, anyways, I'm actually,
uh,
relieved,
believe it or not because I
did the big Papi roast on,
uh,
what was it?
Thursday night and thank Christ it went
about as great as it could have gone.
I am not a big fan of doing rose. You
know what the last roast I did was I did
the Patrice O'Neal roast like
15 years ago or something.
Whenever the hell that was,
that was the last time,
cause I never understood doing one
unless you were friends with the person.
Right. But I always like is, I
always see guys like Lenny class
it dead. And uh, Dennis Leary, uh,
you know, they're always
hanging out at red sox games,
getting up in the broadcast booth.
And I'm like,
I would love to fucking do some shit
like that. I need to do more Boston shit.
So this thing came up and I'm like,
ah, why did it have to be a roast?
And Nia chimed in. She's like, Oh
shit. So I said, yes, I'll do it.
Then I had no time to fucking right cause
that was dealing with a bunch of other
shit and uh,
all of a sudden it was a few days away.
And um, I dealt with that race, that race,
that roast the way this
country dealt with a y two k,
you know what? We waited until the last
second. Then we were like, oh my God,
what are we going to do? Like we treated
it like a fucking giant term paper.
That's what I did.
Um,
and it was a race to Thursday when I
was trying to say a race to the finish
line, a race against time. Um,
and I actually figured out how my brain
works when it comes to those fucking
things.
It's the same way it works for Standup,
but for some reason you think like a
roast. I have to sit down and write jokes.
That's not what I needed to do. I needed
to, to put my daughter is at my joy.
I had to put my daughter in the
stroller and walk around the block.
And then I had to,
uh,
I smoked a cigar by myself on the back
porch and I just kept thinking that shit
and I would just videotape
myself saying it.
And then I had all these videos and
I forget if I told you this guys,
you guys is on a, Oh sorry, on Thursday,
but I just watched the videos and I
just spliced together every good one,
just transcribed them.
And then I had the block of everybody,
right. I had poppy, grump
Pedroia, Josh Wolfe,
Lenny Clack,
Sarah Tiana,
Anthony Mackie and everybody that was on
the fucking thing and I just would put
them underneath
each name and then I just made a new
document and I just took the best of the
best, slit them over. Then I put
them in the best possible order.
Then I went in order of person
and then I smoothed it out.
And um,
yeah,
and it all worked.
Thank fucking Christ.
The only way to make fun of David Ortiz
was to just to make fun of how he looked.
In the fact that he was a DH.
That's all I had.
And I made fun of the Dominican
Republic a little bit. Um,
and that was it. That was it.
So I don't know if this video,
I know Gronk fucking killed
Pedroia killed.
He told his fucking hilarious
story about popping,
not knowing his first name was Dustin.
Somebody said to him like,
poppy was in the batter's box,
not the batter's box.
He was on like the on deck circle.
And podria was stepped out of the batter's
box on called time out of something.
And the catcher just said hello
to Dee, said, hey, what's up?
And when Dustin walked over to poppy
to talk to him, poppy said, he goes,
what the fuck did that guy just say to
you to fuck? Did that guy just call you?
He's, he said, he said, what's
up Dustin? And poppy was like,
what the fuck does that mean? It goes,
ah, that's my first, it's my first name.
Poppy was like re Oh yeah,
like he didn't even know
that his name was [inaudible].
So for is like,
dude, it's my first name. But they
introduced me every time I go up to bed,
I've been going up to bat like
10,000 times. I bet in front of you.
Every time I come to the plate they say,
now batting number 15,
Dustin Pedroia. And it just,
it never clicked with them.
There's another guy I would've gone to
summer school with Petrolia. Got It.
Like I think podria got it the worst.
He was hilarious.
He just kept sitting there like, dude,
what the fuck ever. You know, it was just,
I think he got, you
know, speaking of 11,000,
it was like 11,000 short jokes for him.
So there,
there is clips of it up on the
Internet. Um, it wasn't the greatest
organize thing was the first time they
did it and they didn't know how to do a
roast.
And you can't have people filming at
it because a roast is so over the top.
And that's how people get in
trouble and they, you know,
they take shit out of context
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
It's completely fucking
over the top. So, uh,
you know, I don't know why. I don't
know why they let they let people film.
I don't know why things happened. Why
did things happen like that? But anyways,
I had to go on dead last and everybody
fucking killed Lenny went up first killed
Adam Ray,
went up dressed as a Yankee fan named
Tony and just told everybody in the crowd
to suck his dick and kept trashing yeah.
Big Papi.
And then bragging about the Yankees.
27 championships in the crowd.
Loved it while they were born.
And they also love, and it,
he was fucking hilarious.
Um,
Anthony Mackie killed Sarah Tiana fucking
destroyed probably at my favorite joke
in the night. And then, uh,
fuck eh Gronk went up,
killed,
then put Roya and then I
had to go up last and a,
it's one of those things as you sit there,
you know,
you're kind of losing angles as you go.
So I tried to do,
I tried to just go like a unique way.
So with Gronk I knew everybody was going
to say it was stupid. So I was like,
all right, I'm going to say smart.
I'm going to go that way with it,
by the way, by the way. Um,
he actually was commenting on how he
hates going to concerts and everybody sits
there fucking looking at the concert
through their phone. You know what I mean?
How's fucking stupid that is, I love
everybody thinks that that guy's dumb.
You know, like you can make it to the NFL,
memorize the playbook and all of that,
all that fucking shit you gotta learn
and then go out on the field against the
top athletes on the planet and make split
second decisions and reactions to how
they're reacting to you and people feel
that you can actually get there and just
be this big dumb guy.
I knew he wasn't going to be done when I
met him and he wasn't. So that was a, uh,
that made the shit that I was going
to say about them even better. I mean,
I did one dumb joke, a bond of being
done, but I had to get through it.
I had to do like fucking 10, 12 minutes.
So anyways, it, uh, it went great.
And my favorite, yeah, part of
bought it was a poppy yelled,
fuck you with me?
I've at least three or four times
and I just kept going, fuck you too man.
It's a roast. You wanted to get roasted.
Here we go. And uh, he was
such a fucking great guy.
The guy really is, is a rockstar man.
His whole vibe is a fucking rock stuff.
So when I finished,
he got up off the chair and came over
and gave me a big fucking hug and uh,
and thank me for doing it just to,
just really like one of the great
fucking people I've ever gotten to do
something like that for. So, uh, what
was funny is I had, I had just as much,
I think I had more jokes about Lindy
Clark than I did about poppy just cause I
knew him, which is why I always feel
like if you're going to do a roast,
you should know the person.
And um,
what's hilarious is Lenny has been
clean and sober for like a quarter of a
century.
And a,
all of my jokes were about him
just being a fucking, you know,
complete mania. I, I talked to him
basically like he wasn't sober,
like he had been sober and he was,
you know,
the best guy about a great sport about
itself. Anyways, long story short,
um, I got through it and I told you
once I got through that Gig, my,
the whole rest of my year
fucking nothing easy, easy, easy,
easy peasy. Everything's in my wheelhouse.
It's the weirdest fucking year from me.
I had all the crazy shit
I had to do this. Um, oh,
this year was all in this month.
All of this stuff of just, um,
I haven't thought,
I haven't set worried thinking how the
fuck is this going to go this many times
in one month since back when I
first started out doing standup,
which basically every show I was
going up thinking like, ah, fuck,
commit to your shit. Get that
first laugh, ride the wave,
don't go over, say good night. Get
the fuck out of there, you know?
So, um, that's it. And I'm ready to
go to the summer. The next night.
We all went to the game,
got to see the retirement ceremony and uh,
it was great. Man. Jim Rice
was there. Carl Yastrzemski,
Veritech, Pedro Martinez, um,
Pedroia came out and uh, I got to see the
whole thing, man, they took the, you know,
one covered it,
got to see when they were first put 34 up.
And um,
I got to admit though, part of it was sad.
It was like, fuck, it's over. It's over.
Now he's part of the history
of the Boston red sox.
And UHM,
I dunno.
No, I, I, you know, all
those ceremonies, man,
they was just remind you that
you're gonna fucking die. Like, oh,
now he's too old to play baseball.
He's too old to fucking play.
And I'm like 15 years fucking older
than he is at 10 years older than him,
you know.
Okay.
So you can call your strep ski
coming out with all white hair.
Yeah.
I should've known that was coming. That
guy played until he was like fucking 40.
Oh my God, I'm on nine years
older than when that guy retired.
Maybe play the like 43. I don't fucking
know. This is getting depressing.
How do I get out of this? How the
fuck do I get out of this? Oh, I know.
Let's talk f one and fucking
Moto GP. Pete, Pete, Pete. Um,
all right.
So race number fucking eight or nine
of the f one a season in Azerbaijan.
Is that [inaudible] as her by
Jan [inaudible], Jan, whatever.
Just east of Georgia
and I don't mean fucking
Georgia United States, the country,
Georgia and I guess it's in Asia.
It's not eastern Europe. I was
getting, it's always weird,
Georgia and all the way over there. You
don't know where the fuck they're at. Uh,
one of the coolest cities.
MMM.
On the f one circuit using that word
circuit. Uh, just a beautiful city.
I would love to go there,
but I definitely looked up like,
is that like a one of those
places I shouldn't go? Should
I have like a Canadian,
a fucking flag on my backpack?
Should I speak in an Irish
brogue when I go there?
I'm seeing like it was pretty safe.
I don't know. I don't fucking know.
I had a great time.
What crazy God damn fucking race.
Congratulations to Daniel Ricardo,
who I take might be the best driver in
f one considering he doesn't have the
best engine and he's always
on the fucking podium.
Any drinks champagne out of
his fucking shoe. So you know,
God bless you. And I dunno about
this Lewis Hamilton guy. I was a fan.
I think he's a fucking great driver,
but I don't know.
They said he didn't hit the brakes
flow did you guys don't watch it?
They want to caution the fucking
safety car was out there. You know,
guys always complained that the safety
car drives too fucking slow, you know,
which cools off to tires.
Then they don't have any grip and then
they slam into the fucking wall or into
each other. Right. So anyways,
Hamilton was complaining that the fucking
guy was driving too slow and then for
whatever reason he hits
the brakes really hard.
And Sebastian Vettel rear ended him and
he was like, what the fuck? And then he,
fennel pulls up alongside of them,
slammed his cars and like, you know,
tire to tire and a,
he got a ten second penalty for that.
And um,
I dunno, I kind of view it and they said
to Hamilton, didn't slam on the brakes,
but I kind of viewed this as one of
the, the ball don't lie. You know,
they say that in basketball when there's
some piece of shit file bullshit,
file guide flops, you go up there
and you miss the foul shots.
They would say the ball don't lie.
Well only a after that thing they
said Hamilton Slam on the brakes.
Hamilton and slam on the brakes and
federal was guilty as slamming into him.
And the only game at ten second penalty,
I guess they said they should have
been more, uh, so be basically,
he has to drive into the fucking pits
and sit there for 10 seconds as everybody
keeps going and then drives back
out again. But Hamilton, after that,
uh, that fucking thing that goes around
his neck or whatever outside the car,
that thing came loose.
So he had the fucking Poland anyways,
which fucked him over and
Vettel still beat him.
So I looked at that like the ball
don't lie and Hamilton, fuck.
I didn't like how he fucking said
Deeks says to his team saying,
poultice should slow down. He should
slow down to help me pack federal.
Go Fuck Yourself.
What about last year when the team calls
you up to slow down for fucking Nico
Rosberg and you're like, Nah, I'm good.
You are out there driving fee itself.
You know what that guy reminds me of?
He reminds me of a couple of comedians.
I'm not going to fucking mentioned their
names when I was on that one my way up
with them and they were
these fucking people.
They were happy if you've got something,
as long as they had more and they would
literally stab your mother in the eye if
they could get an inch forward. That's
what I got out of that fucking shit. Hey,
she'd slow down and go,
fuck you got fucking Mercedes Benz engine.
That isn't enough for you.
I still like Lewis Hamilton,
but that was kind of girly. That
was kind of girly. I thought,
you know what I mean? I might
be out of my fucking mind. Yeah.
I don't like that shit is what I don't
like about f one is basically the fucking
Mercedes and the Ferrari's.
Okay.
If you don't root for either one of
those other teams, every other team,
it's like they're out there driving
around in a fucking z 28. Okay.
And Ferrari and Mercedes, they're
driving around in a corvette. Coo Six.
Seeing that lance stroll,
he was like 10 seconds ahead of uh,
uh, both tests. What happened to him
at the early part of the race? Oh,
they already buy the rights. Everybody
fucking hit each other in the beginning.
So he had to go and he was immediately
a lap down. He's a lap down.
He does his stroke erase shit.
Like a fucking movie just flies
through the entire fucking field.
I mean Daniel Ricardo did the same thing,
but he sees in the red bull thing,
they got to get inferior engine. Like
they won't give him one of those Mercedes,
they won't sell the guy a Mercedes or
a Ferrari engine. Cause he knows he,
he be too much of a problem.
That's why I think he's the best driver
out there cause he's driving around and
basically a fucking z 28 and he's
always up on the podium. So anyways,
um, for Cindy and my fucking team there,
I don't know what's going on with them.
They got this whole Ricky,
Bobby, Ricky bubby shit going on,
slamming into each other.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Esteban Khan and Sergio Perez,
they basically took each
other out of the race.
They would have been on the podium one,
possibly two cars and for
half a fucking second.
What is it t the Haas team.
The fucking American team.
Magnuson was like in third place.
All right.
Two of the Williams give us
the craziest fucking race.
Like the front of the race was Daniel
Ricardo like both Williams, Martini,
Martini racing, whatever the
fuck you said. And uh, Magnuson.
Then of course they all just get run down.
They all get fucking rundown.
Both was like 10 seconds behind stroll
with like 10 laps to go and he fucking
caught him right at the finish
line to get second place.
Um,
so that's it.
I can no longer route for fucking
Ferrari and I can't root for a Mercedes
because I feel like I'm root for the
Yankees or the Red Sox, you know,
reason why I root for the red sox.
It's cause I'm from Boston.
What am I supposed to do? But like, you
know, they both blow to what? $1 million,
but not this year.
The Yankees have it.
But I'm just saying generally speaking
throughout history, right. So I can't,
I can't like pile on,
pull a Kevin Durant or Lebron down
in Miami or the big three in Boston,
two out of three anyways. Um, I can't
fucking do that. So my team, my teams,
I like, I liked the forced Cindy
India team and I liked the, uh,
the Williams racing team. That's
the coolest looking car, I think.
I like their colors. You
know, red, white and blue.
I guess they used to dominate though.
I got to read up more on this sport.
I don't get how you used to fucking
dominate then everybody, you just suck.
You know,
I don't get it.
It's not like other sports where you've
got athletes getting old and dying,
not dying, retiring, I should say. I mean,
if you know how to make a fucking
engine work at that level,
shouldn't you just know how to do it?
I know,
I know the driver does count
for something, but gee,
I don't fucking know what I'm saying.
I don't know shit about this stuff.
I just know it's fun to watch.
I guess red bull won like three in a row,
like I don't know, five, six years ago.
And then all of a sudden what engine
where they use and then bold look it up,
Bill.
I'm afraid to,
I'm afraid to look it up and it'll be
like fucking p's and q's and no one will
have an answer. So I watched that
today. And then I also watched the, uh,
the Moto GP race, which was
fucking insane. Both races.
What great. The Moto GP race was
even fucking better. Like is crazy.
Is that race was, did they have a problem
with that? Uh, as a by Jan race where,
because it goes through a city that you
don't have those cranes to lift the cars
out of the way and this fucking
debris all over the track. Um,
they actually had a red flag
and everybody just pulled in.
It just stopped is all these guys were
running around the track picking up shit
from other cars that is smashed into
each other. As crazy as that race was,
the motor GP race was,
was the Shit Valentino Rossi.
It's like 38 fucking years old.
He ended winning the thing. Um,
just imagine all the
bullshit that was happened.
F One with them bumping into each other.
They're doing it on motorcycles going
like 150, 200 fucking miles an hour.
Um, you know who the guy
I liked the best on the,
I mean I always root for Valentino Rossi
just cause he's old and I relate and I
want him to keep winning. So it
doesn't make me feel like, you know,
when he retires that my God, there's
another guy. Um, I liked that.
Johann Johann Zarko, that guy's a fucking
lunatic. And I also liked the color,
the bike, the black and the yellow,
whatever it got. Um, I liked him. I liked,
and then I also like, uh, the Ducati team.
I liked that. How you
say his last name? Dov.
A coc. Seals. So I can't say it.
I can't say someone's got to say I got
to watch another 15 races to be able to
pronounce that. Dov. I Z I o so
zoo.
So
Doe Dovi Dovizioso Dovizioso
Sat. I said German, Irish,
like we usually have two syllable once.
Silva fucking last names. I can't, that's,
that's too many fucking hills.
Dovizioso Andrea Dovizioso.
Gatsy prego. Uh, just an
incredible fucking race.
Mac Marquez was in there too. Um,
and then that fucking lunatic, the,
the British guy, cal crutch low. I
don't know where the fuck he came from.
That guy rides like a [inaudible]
the way he wrote it. Yo hands.
Zarko I liked them. They're out of
their fucking mind. Um, so I'm gonna,
I'm, I'm all in on both of those
races. It's so fucking easy to watch.
20 something lapse. And then the, uh, the
one today with the cars was like, what?
Like 50 fucking labs? 51.
It's a good goddamn time.
And then after that I take
my daughter out. You know,
a lot of people when they
want to get their babies to
fall asleep, a lot of dads,
what they do is they put him in
the car and they drive around.
It's hilarious because the
movement makes him go to sleep.
But then you get to a red light and they
wake up and they start crying again.
That's why I am a big proponent
of the stroller. All right.
Cause you can keep that fucking thing.
If he had a red light, you can keep it,
you know,
if you're walking.
And also it's a great way to
prevent the dreaded dad bod.
Okay?
All you fucking guys out there,
you throw them in the car and
then you drive around, you know,
then they fall asleep
and then what do you do?
You hit the drive through
because you're tired. You know,
Arby's,
we have the meats and then you get that
fucking sandwich that Osa has a pig on
it. The pork, the spare ribs or whatever
the fuck they put on there. The ribs,
the hoof, the hough. Um,
yeah,
I've been just walking
around my neighborhood and
she falls asleep and then,
uh, I just keep walking throughout her
whole nap and went to the fucking butcher,
went to the supermarket,
knock out some errands as she's asleep.
You just keep it fucking
moving the whole time.
You throw the groceries on the
bottom of the stroller and that's it.
It's a little dad tip for you.
If you got, he got a better one.
I don't know what to tell you.
I do the elliptical while she's
still sleeping in the morning,
and then I take her for a trip around
the neighborhood. You got to do it.
He can't, you can't do the car thing.
Then you've got to go out and walk,
put on your track suits, right.
Track shoes, your dad's socks,
you fucking Jean shorts,
whatever the fuck you got going on.
You're a true religion.
Jeans.
I love that. I never gave it to
that fed. Those were the z cavalry.
She's a fucking last decade
giant stitching with the fucking,
you want to get lucky boy
fucking horse shoe on the back.
Uh, there was always something funny
about a horse shoe on the ass pockets that
always to me was more
gay pride parade than a
Fuckin a little fucking chicks over
there. But they fuck, they loved them.
They loved them.
And speaking of fucking the
Gay Pride Parade, you know,
it's slowly making a comeback and I love
it cause I never had a problem with it
is rollerblading.
Rollerblading is slowly making a comeback.
I loved it. I used to go down the
beach with my short shorts on,
skating backwards,
getting little boy short true religion boy
shorts. I did it. We share. We all did.
Ah, there's the Photoshop for
the week, but you know what,
there's no fucking true religion. Boy
Shorts. It good luck with you on that one.
Fuck. Oh um, no. I liked that.
I used to play fucking a in New York
and out in Santa Monica down in Venice
beach.
I used to play roller hockey and uh,
Jesus Christ catching an edge never hurt
more than when you were in a fucking
parking lot. Ugh. You
had to go elbow pads,
you had to do an elbow and knee pads.
You just had to fucking do it, you know,
out there dressed like robocop
because when you went down you were,
you were fucked. And the only thing
that sucked as though the hockey gloves,
he didn't have that thing.
And I actually broke my wrist or broke a
bone in my wrist. I used to his eye his,
oh my God. Way Back. Way, way, way
back. Way Back in the fucking day.
I used to play two one to
roller blade hockey at the,
on the top of parking
garages in West Hollywood.
Um,
I used to play in with three other comics.
It was me and Dane Cook and it was
versus through all Boston comics versus a
Rick Dalea and rest his
soul, a peak coming. And,
uh,
I remember we used to,
I remember playing the day of the
Superbowl just laughing at how insane the
fucking weather was that it was
80 degrees out. We went out there,
had a great fucking game, super,
super highly competitive fucking game.
And we used to play at the top of the
parking garage because for whatever reason
on like the Sundays or whatever,
they would just never,
there wouldn't be enough people.
No one wanted to park on the roof because
the car would get all fucking hot on
the inside and we would play up there
and sometimes someone will park up there,
but no one would ever rat us out.
And only a couple of times did the ball
ever go over the edge that I remember.
But we always had like an extra one.
But uh,
we do that all the time and
it was a great time. And uh,
I never understood why the
whole fucking fad went away.
There was one homophobic joke,
one homophobic joke killed the,
what's the hardest thing about roller
blading? Telling your parents, telling,
telling your parents that you gay. That
one little joke, the whole fucking thing.
The whole thing went away. I never
understood it. I got to the point,
I was the one that the guy who took his
break off, that was like a big thing.
And you lived in New York,
you had to be cool.
You had to take your break off and learn
how to stop the other way. Like, yeah,
why would I want to be able to stop quick
when I'm skating out in traffic with
cabs and shit? I can't
believe I never died. Um,
I had a couple of really close calls,
so fucking stupid.
I would never do that again. I just
chalked that up to uh, being young.
Like I still lived in New York
and I was close to Central Park,
Clark Clark Park and I was going
to go rollerblading. I would,
I would at this my age,
I would walk to the park carrying
my fucking roller blades.
I have no shame about it.
I know a lot of people are
embarrassed that they rollerbladed.
I have no fucking shame.
No shame.
If I lived closer to a boardwalk, I would
own a pair and I would go out there.
It's so much more fun than
doing the fucking elliptical.
It's better exercise. You know, you
put on your wireless headphones, right?
You tie his tee tee shirt off
at the waist and you know,
you'd go out there and you have a good
time. Maybe you have some tassels on.
I don't know why I am.
I think it's hilarious that everybody
got all fucking weird about it. Um,
as you can tell,
I haven't read any advertising.
I haven't done any fucking
questions because a,
I'm recording it early and I still
haven't gotten my materials for the week.
Let's hit refresh. See if they
came in. Let's see. Nothing,
nothing, nothing. No
advertising, no nothing. All
right, I'll keep talking here.
I'll keep talking. I'll read the
ads and then I'll do the fucking,
I'll do the fucking, uh, what do you
call it? Uh, I'll do the questions.
All right. Um, all right. No Dad Bod.
Ernie talked about that. Oh, Billy.
No Fun. Billy. No Fun. Billy. No Fun.
Didn't drink until Friday night.
Um,
took my nephew to the game
and after I dropped him off,
I went back into the city and I
add a two home pores and a fucking,
uh,
an a in a cigar.
But then I didn't drink last night and
today had one cause like, just cause they,
they made the old stubby bottles again.
I just had to add one and it was fucking
delicious. But I don't count that.
I just had one. I didn't
get fucked up. Um, anyways,
so I've been doing that shit.
Got The drinking back under control and
um, I'm going gonna find out this week,
by the way, if there's going to be
a season three of f is for family,
so I'm a little nervous,
um, to find out. So,
uh,
if you haven't watched it yet,
it would really help us if you guys would
watch this week to give a nice little
boost.
You know,
I know there's a ton of good shit out
there and know bloodline came back and it
was of you guys are working
your way through Fargo or
better call Saul. But, uh,
if you could just give us just, you
know, watch one episode, something,
anything will help. Um, cause we're
going to find out this week. And um,
so anyways,
I went to the red sox Friday night.
Saturday I came home and the angel's
game was on against the red sox cause you
know, I get the angels feed out here
and now back into watching baseball.
I'm watching racing and I actually watched
the end of the BCA eagles versus the
Edmonton Eskimos.
I watched the CFL game.
I gotta tell you it was highly
entertaining because the BC eagles fucking
defense sucks.
MMM.
One of those high scoring games or
whatever. They tied it up and then,
you know what,
lighten it up with like no time left.
And the Edmonton Eskimos go out in
the first fucking play. They gave up,
I don't know, a nice 80 yard meter,
whatever the fuck they call it,
a kilometer of whatever they
call it up there a pass.
And then they lost the game,
kicked a field goal and it was over.
And I had a lot of people, shit on
the CFL. It's on Tsn. It's good shit.
You know,
I look at it this way,
this is college players that
weren't good enough to make it,
you know, into the, uh,
into the NFL. But any,
any one of those CFL teams could beat
the best fucking college team out there
cause it's made of college. All stars
like the NFL, it's college, all stars.
The NFL is just the best of
the best college. All stars.
The CFL is all the college, all stars
that could not make it to the NFL.
So it's still competitive football.
They got that giant field.
I actually enjoyed it. Um, I dunno,
I always watched like the Edmonton Eskimos
just because like way back in the day
it always seem like Doug Flutie
and Warren Moon or some shit.
We're always on those
teams. Um, but you know, I,
I don't know, BC eagles came back, so
I was like, I gotta I gotta Watch this,
I'm going to root for these guys and
they fuck the game up. Um, all right.
I don't know what else to talk about.
I'm running out of shit.
A congratulations to the lady in Australia
who breastfed in on in parliament.
I don't know why that was a big deal,
but evidently it's big deal.
I don't know what I have to be honest
with you. My whole fucking life.
I've never heard one guy ever say that
he had an issue with breastfeeding in
public.
I don't know what the fucking problem is.
MMM.
I think it's more for like guys that don't
have kids yet and it like grosses him
out because they're like,
I want to be sticking my face in there
and now there's a baby there and that
weirds me out and it
makes my chubby go away.
I don't know what the deal is. I also
don't think I, but I'd be honest with you,
I don't think you should be breastfeeding
while you're fucking, you know,
working for your district, you know, can,
can we have your 100% focus
here? You know, I dunno.
I guess guys could go up
there and adjust their balls.
Is that talking about
laws? I Dunno. I Dunno why.
I don't know what the
big deal is about it. Uh,
I've seen it my whole fucking life,
but I also don't know why it's treated
like somebody just landed on Mars and
came back. You know, anything
women do is now, it's just like,
it was so great. It was so groundbreaking,
you know, they try to act like, you know,
they were, they weren't
Braveheart, so like you fed a baby
cause it was hungry. Um, I'm
Brian and I's shit to talk about.
Royal blood has a new album out. Everybody
now. I didn't download their first one.
I just downloaded that hit and I played
my drums to it a thousand times and I
still suck at it, you know,
then something some to do,
but [inaudible] gotta fucking work it
out. Wham, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam,
Bam, Bam. Blow blow, blow blow payment.
[inaudible] he did the cabbage do the
blue. However the fucking song goes.
I don't even know the words.
Um,
well what did,
what did a ball?
Uh, royal blood has a new album
out and it got good reviews,
so I'm going to download that
shit cause I have a fucking,
I got a little rehearsal space. I was
over there today. I was over there today.
I got my fucking life down. It's
perfect. Wake up in the morning.
I work out right where the kids sleep
in. My wife's sleeping. Then I run over.
I played drums for a fucking hour.
I come back like a champ.
I make everybody breakfast, you
know, I get my bullshit done.
And then in the afternoon I uh,
take my fucking precious
little baby girl for a walk.
That's it. That's it. But you know what?
My wife will still find something
to complain to me about something.
I something there'll be
something I'm doing wrong.
I just feel like I would
like it better if you,
I feel like for me. Um, all right,
this is the last thing that I got to hit
pause until this fucking shit comes in.
Uh, the questions here, come on
man. Send the fucking questions.
Refresh button. Hit the refresh button.
Bill. Hit the refresh button. Nothing.
Wait a minute. I'm an asshole.
Ah, it was in the wrong account.
What an asshole.
What?
And that is the kind of guy who
doesn't know the difference between
photosynthesis and pollination
fighting out of the blue corner.
Here we go. Oh, and Lo and behold,
there it is and we go out.
It's time for some advertising.
I was just going to
give you guys a fun bit.
Baseball fact remind me when I come
back, he can't, but I'll, I'll, you know.
All right.
Oh Boto
Doh, me, undies, me undies.
They used to be two.
All Star Games do do to to me on
these B and e's between 1959 in 1960
too. And everybody went up
to plate. Their balls hurt.
They didn't know what to do cause the
suits were made a wall in have far,
that one sucked. I gotta take two on that
one. I tried to give you the all state.
There was two all star games
in 1959 60 61 and I believe 62.
Um, I might as well give it to you now,
right? Might as well tell it to you.
Why not? You know why it is. Do you know
why they had to all star games? Not,
because you know,
people couldn't afford to travel.
So they had one on the east coast,
one on the west coast. It wasn't that,
it wasn't every, okay.
It turns out that, uh,
playing of the second game was intended
to increase the amount of money going to
the players pension fund.
Uh, this person says,
I wish there was a
neater reason than that,
like gambling demands or trial
formation of an allstar league,
which would be made up of
two teams of all stars.
I played each other a hundred times a
season, but nope. Pension Fund. That's it.
And everybody realized by 1962 or
so that the arrangement was dumb.
Uh, the public at large is
finding a second all star game,
something of an anticlimax like playing
a second world series in Brazil.
So 1951, 1960, 61,
1959, sorry, 60 61. They played
to all star Games. There you go.
And I learned that this weekend when I
saw a pennant from Fenway about the 1961
all star games and they called the
Cincinnati reds, by the way, the red legs,
which I had never heard of
either. Hey Bill, why don't
you get to the advertising?
Because that was some of the most boring
shit I've ever listened to in my life.
Hey, hey. Hey. Fair enough. Oh, but
Doto Mandy's me undies. Mind you fucking
cues and ps to do to to me undies.
Me undies.
I can't fucking sing it this week.
I've got nothing this week.
My brain is fried for my dollars.
Roast jokes.
I thought if I was ended with peas
and gave me some Orion's, we undies,
Mandy's man, you fucking p's
and q's to do to to me on these.
Me On these.
Don't pee pee or do the Doodoo and
you fucking velvet fucking underwear.
If you shed,
no one will care because it'll be soft
and cradle the air in the chain of your
phone as gross.
All right.
Mian he's everybody talk about why
you think it's important to have great
underwear. Oh cause it doesn't ride
up on your balls and Dick there.
You perfected your wardrobe.
But what about the stuff?
Everybody every not gets to cs c sorry.
If you've been settling for store,
bought underwear, five packs.
I have something that will change your
life for the better. It's me undies.
Everyone. What's the first thing you
put on? The last thing you take off?
It's your underwear.
Unless you're Matthew Mcconaughey,
make your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me undies.
What is me undies?
Just seriously saw.
Feel good undies delivered
right to your front Doula.
Me undies are designed in La and made
from sustainably sourced it. Micro Modal,
modal,
a fabric three times softer than cotton.
Well why don't we clean out our ears
with it then me or wipe our ass with it.
I mean if you just telling me that
this shit is better than cotton,
well guess cotton is natural me on the
softer than soft luxury undies come in
and ever changing selection
of classic colors,
bold shades and adventurous plat patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your
own personal style. And guess what?
You can save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription.
If you're not ready for a description,
that's okay man. You can still save.
That's because me undies is
offering 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burn and get
20% off your first pair. Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr me,
undies.com/burr oh, I love it. There's
only three or four reads this week.
All right. How likes helix? Your unique,
you're a special little fucking snowflake.
You don't walk like everyone else talk
like everyone else. Show chat, uh,
sleep life for everyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because a truly customized mattress
will cost you five to $10,000.
Until now, go to Heloc,
sleep.com he leaks.
Answer a few simple questions,
and they'll run a three d biomechanical
model of your body through their
proprietary algorithms they develop
with the help of the world's leading
irrigant comics and biomechanics experts.
The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've
ever slept on, he looks Hellickson.
Customers report at 30% improvement in
overall sleep quality and for couples for
fucking,
they customize each side of the mattress.
You can fuck your a,
you can fuck somebody else while
your partner is still sleeping.
Your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week in the shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine
to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep.com you'll hit you have 100 nights
to try it out and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free grubs and
give you 100% refund. No questions.
Jacks ass. Go to Helen's sleep.com/burr
and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/bar hey, how? Like
sleep.com/birth spelled h
e l I x dollar Shave Club,
dude, dollar shave club.
Is this smart at choice?
I talked to this guy this weekend.
Then he had like one of those Boston
accents that it sounds like he's slurring.
I'll try to recreate it.
You'll get a gray shave and a great price.
Conveniently delivered right to your door.
I know you no longer have to Schlep
to the store to buy a cheap disposable
razors that gives you a cheap shave.
Dude,
I spent a fortune on razors with
gimmicky shit. I can't even do it.
Gimmicky shaving tech technology you
don't even need and when you use Eh,
uh,
dollar Shave Club's executive razor
with the Dr Covey's easy shea.
Okay.
The blade just gently glides
giving you a smooth shave.
Dr Carver's shave butter is
transparent for a more precise shave,
helps prevent ingrown hairs
and feels great on your bulls.
Make the smarter choice by joining
Dollar Shave Club for a limited time.
New members can get their first month
of the executive razor with a tube of
carvings,
cheesy shape for only $5 off for
for only $5 with free shipping.
After that,
razors are just a few dollars a month.
That's a $15 value for only five bucks.
There are no hidden fees,
no commitments.
Cancel anytime you like.
You can only get this offer
exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com.
That's dollar shave club.com
one more for God's sakes.
I rolled friends.
She would,
old acquaintance be forgot and their copy.
Not Be red stamps.com stamps.
Save you time and money,
but you can use to grow your business.
You can mail any letter, any package
using just your computer or printer.
And the mailman comes and picks
it up. That's right, the mail man.
He's not breastfeeding while he
walks to the God damn mailbox.
He's grabbing his balls,
walking right up to walk.
Avoid the hassle man of the post office
and mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments. Unlike the
post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage or letters
or packaged for what?
Print postage for letters or packages
at your, at your convenience.
24 seven keywords descriptions,
convenient, easy, reliable,
flexible.
A stamps.com brings all the service
of the US post office right to your
fingertips. Buy and print official US
postage for any letter, any package,
any classes. Mail using your
own computer and printer. Uh,
no need to lease an
expensive postage meter.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm selling
posters afterwards, my after my shows,
if I want a whore myself out, if I can
figure it out, God damn it. You can't too.
And right now you too can enjoy stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
enter.
Thanks frigging God,
I'm done with that shit.
I hate doing a lot of reads during
the summer. All right, here we go.
Let's read some of the content,
some of the content. Oh Hey, I got,
I gotta promote a Paul Versey show.
Paul Versey with the hilarious Mike Favor.
Min Our co headlining a comedy show
to help raise awareness to fight.
That's film intervening,
getting high team.
Okay.
Jesus Christ says a fucking mouthful at
a nonprofit that helps young adolescents
tell inspiring stories through film
and video creations that help curb the
opiate epidemic. Uh,
founded by oxymoron writers,
oxymorons writer slash director
Johnny Hickey. Ever see that movie?
That's a good one. Check that one out. Um,
they're doing the show at the cow Luna
on route one in Saugus this Thursday,
July 29th,
seven to 10:00 PM free buffet
with ticket purchase a of $40.
All right.
Go to the Calhoun route one saga.
Some of the best fucking Chinese food
you ever going to have Paul Versey might
favor. Men are going to fucking
kill it. Seven and 10:00 PM what?
Seven seven dash 10:00 PM and there's
two shows. One show seven to 10.
I don't know what it is. Look it up. All
right. Kyle alluded. Route one. Saugus.
All right, three drink
rule. A bill bull bag tits.
I have three drinks tonight and went home.
I feel great about myself
from a fellow adult. Ooh.
Little shade there in the end.
I Dunno dude. Three drinks.
She'll become a bloated fat. Fuck you
had three drinks and he drove home.
What kind of drinks?
Um, all right, here's,
here's one for you buddy.
I drank probably over 300 days last year.
I don't feel good about myself.
Um,
and me needing to shut it down in no
way should make you feel self conscious
about what you're doing to the point you
have to be contained to me and say you
feel great about yourself. Um, all
right. That's it. So good for you.
Keep having three drinks a night and
feel good about yourself when you don't
feel good about yourself. Shut it
down. You know what I'll do? I'll yet
cancer charity sham. Oh,
here we go. Here we go.
Here's another one.
In a rare joint action with the attorney
or attorneys general for each of the 50
states,
the Federal Trade Commission says for
cancer charities run by extended members
of the same family con donors out of a
$187 million from 2008 to 2012 and spent
almost nothing to help actual cancer
patients. And what happens to these
people? Are they going to go to jail?
Children's cancer fund.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
In a rare bubba by read each of the
charities charge where the subject of
extensive reporting by CNN in 2013 I,
cause I remember this story and in each
instance none of the four charities
would comment.
We were ordered out of the building at
the cancer fund of America in Knoxville,
Tennessee, home of the
Tennessee volunteers, uh,
and worthy object of an abyss of an
obscene gesture by the CEO of the breast
cancer society. Am I,
that's usually, you know,
that's usually a good
sign that it's bullshit.
If you're raising money for cancer for
a to help kids stricken with cancer and
you're the CEO and you give the finger
of media which is going to help promote,
yeah,
that's probably a good sign.
The Cancer Fund of America is run
by James rendered senior, his son,
James Ronald Jr.
This is all alleged by the way,
before these scumbags allegedly
start to sue me for reading.
This is the CEO of the breast
cancer society. Another charity,
the child's cancer fund of
America is run by Rose Perkins,
the ex wife of the elder James Reynolds.
He is. He's also the CEO of the Fourth
Charity Cancer Support
Support Server Services.
Ah, wow. Wow. Well,
if they are doing dirt, I hope they get
caught and they'd go to fucking jail.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. Man. That is
like some sociopath shit.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God. And you going out
and buying like a fucking,
when I buy yourself a raptor,
like a fucking,
what could you be? Here's something
for you. What could you by yourself
with,
with cancer.
Okay.
Shit that was supposed to go to it to
help kids. What could you by yourself?
Oh my God, that that is that. I
mean that is just added. It's just,
that's on another fucking level.
I think even bankers would be like,
really do Jesus Christ.
How about a little fucking little
bit of tact? Something. Um,
alright. Transgender habits. A Billy
muffin top. Aww, that's so true.
I listened to Andrew. Yeah.
Had a few months ago, maybe
even a few years ago. Oh,
Jesus. Sorry. Losing credibility.
I can't remember the last month or
2010 I heard a segment you might be
interested in.
I believe it was this American life,
but they asked a transgendered man,
uh,
okay.
I don't know what they mean. A woman
becoming a man. I get it. I think, uh,
if there was any interesting changing,
well he talked about after his transition,
he was now more into science,
was way more interested in sex and wasn't
able to access his emotions as much
anymore.
Okay.
Oh,
so those are basically guy things.
Yeah.
That's kind of interesting.
I would think way more interested in
sex because you're finally is sex.
You want to be science
that's really interesting and
weren't able to access your
emotions for, I dunno. I have no
idea. That's, well, there you go.
So maybe I wasn't wrong thinking that
somebody's habits changed a female
privilege. Hey Man, uh, love your podcast.
Hope your family's doing great.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
Wasn't that Nice of you? My family is
doing great. My daughter is awesome.
And my wife, I have a whole new
level of love for watching a Bmr. No.
Have a read at this article
when you get a chance.
Uh, okay. Female nurse found
guilty of dangerous driving,
causing death to be sentenced.
Do I want to read this?
There weren't any kids involved
in this. This, this gone.
We already saw a potential scam.
Okay. Be Seniors found
guilty of dangerous driving,
causing death sentenced
to 90 days in jail.
The families of two young people are
angry over a dangerous driving sentence,
giving the woman who killed them.
Okay.
The be seniors found guilty
of dangerous driving,
causing death to two people's been
sentenced to 90 days in jail and
Alina Hesi Mobic was driving
at high speeds through pet
pit meadows. And October,
2010 she ran a red light,
jumped a concrete median and slammed
into a car carrying Becky Dyer 19 and
Johnny d all Avera 21 the couple who were
on their way home from a concert where
killed instantly along
with the 90 day sentence.
Hesi Mobic also received
two years probation,
120 hours of community service in
three years driving probation. Yeah.
MMM.
Yeah.
She will serve her sentence intermittently
between Tuesdays and Thursdays around
her work schedule.
Oh my God.
What a joke. Diyers mother. Debbie said,
this sentence is not showing the public
that our justice system actually is a
justice system.
It's actually a legal system.
It's not going to deter other
drivers from doing the same.
Oh my God. D all of error. Mom,
Audrey echoed the same sentiment.
Six years is a long time.
She's put everybody through and
she's only getting a little bit here.
A little bit there. It's
wrong. Yeah. That's terrible.
Okay.
That's fucking terrible.
That's fucking horrible.
Yeah.
You know, at some point when you're
driving that fast, you do. I mean,
I think those laws are all
going to change. I know they
have with drunk driving.
Okay.
I think because she wasn't drunk
in jails are all filled up,
at least in this country.
Like I don't understand that.
But I mean your life should be
tremendously effective if you,
if you were driving that fucking fast
and then killed two innocent people.
Yeah.
I think the whole, well, she's never
committed a crime. She's a nurse.
She's a productive member of society.
I think a lot of that goes
out the fucking window. Well,
she did something tremendously stupid.
And now two people are dead forever.
So at the very least you can
do 90 straight days in jail.
What do you say there and yeah,
I guess you'll have to figure
out what you're going to fail.
You're going to find another job after
that. What kind of cool job does she have?
I have to be on jail.
I've been in jail on Tuesday and
Thursdays because I killed two people on
Tuesday. I go to jail for the
woman I killed on Thursday.
I go to jail for the guy I killed.
Felt like,
can I work like Monday,
not Wednesdays.
So there'll be like so tired
from being jail from one day. Um,
can I work like Monday, Friday,
Saturday and a half day Sunday?
Uh, that's, yeah. That's disgusting.
Fucking disgusting. All right.
My girlfriend is becoming a
feminist. Hey there, daddy bald.
Freckle. First of all, English
is, isn't my mother tongue.
So sorry if I fucked up a bit. All
right. I was wondering why that
I could just see you googling daddy bold,
freckle and just mash a muscle
and I would've done all right.
And I'm 33 years old and I'm an 18 and
18 months relationship with a terrific
girl. After four rather
unsuccessful relationship,
I finally had the feeling
she could be the one, uh, um,
she has her flaws like every
person, but hey, so do I.
But when it comes down to the important
features like honesty, moral values,
similar lifestyles and interests,
she really is my match.
And to top it all off in bed,
it never gets boring. Dude,
this is your second language. This is
great. She's more on the submissive side.
Maybe you just fucking with me. And he
deliberately wrote a bad in cell. Um,
she's more in the submit for this side.
If you understand wink and some
things sometimes get wild gross,
gross. I now have no sympathy
for you, but in a very nice way.
He tries to say after our
sexy time session gross,
we lay next to each other comp.
Ah,
completely out of breath
feeling like nothing can touch.
His sounds cheesy but it's
really beautiful. Why did
you go into all that detail?
Oh my God,
that was disgusting.
They ever tell you guys how much I can't
stand watching people kiss in public on
film or any of that. It's, it's
the grossest fucking thing ever.
Keep your intimacies to yourself.
Now we have a long distance relationship.
We are far away but we still eat.
You see still see each other quite often.
Five times per year,
but then usually weeks at a time too.
What the fuck just happened?
What? Johanna will just happen.
There was a,
was there a jump in time here?
Was there some time travel going on here?
She lives in Europe and has been hanging
out with these feminist activist girls
and she's bringing up the topic of sexism,
et Cetera.
More and more lately now I was raised
by a proud mother from, oh Jesus.
Is there any other kind,
proud,
strong woman and could not
imagine dating a girl that has,
has values of women out of
the 1950s I like confident,
proud women. This is what he always
sets himself up to be a good guy.
They can hold their own. But even though
I am not a chauvinist by any means,
I think the modern feminist movement,
similar to Vegans, annoying the living,
annoys the living hell out of me.
I get that there is sexism in this world,
but I don't see the huge problem in it,
especially since the western societies
have made such progress in this field in
the past decades. Yeah.
I mean, I don't know.
You keep talking yourself back
into the holder. Yeah. Like a,
like a total psycho 100% feminist maniac.
Yeah.
You don't wanna be around that.
It's literally like being
around a conspiracy theorist
after awhile as far as,
they're never going to shut the fuck up
about that topic and it's gonna drive
you nuts after awhile.
Um,
do you realize that every day 40% of women
are going to be throwing stats at you?
Like someone who plays fantasy
football? Um, anyway, he says today,
my girlfriends sent me a link to an
article about how pornography objectifies
his discriminates women.
Then she wrote,
I've been thinking a lot lately and how
to change some things in the future,
especially in our sex life. Yeah,
dude, this relationship is over a now.
I tend to agree with now I tend to agree
with this auto button. Nevertheless,
I furiously your pied,
Hey,
if you're going to turn into one of
the these nonstop nagging feminist,
please tell me now so I can even move
the fuck further away from you and your
victim seeking miserable friends.
Yeah, dude, you're kind of an asshole.
You're kind of an asshole.
MMM.
Slash a bit of a control freak I think.
I Dunno.
But then you're cool with her moving away.
I don't know. I can't read you. He goes,
then things escalated quickly.
Yeah.
You think we got into a big fight and
haven't communicated since? Yeah. Dude,
it's so rapid. It was already a rep.
It was already a wrap. You know,
if you just imagine if you
got into something. Okay.
And then you came home and whatever
your new fucking way of thinking was.
You told your wife or girlfriend that
she needed to adjust some things in the
bedroom? I mean, try that
one on for size. Yeah.
What it is is she's grown in a
different direction and she needs to be,
um, you know, I don't, I don't know.
She was with a different type of guy.
Not You. Now Bill, this is a girl.
This girl is great and smart and Tbh.
I don't know what that means.
I am all for women's rights and see
sexism on a daily basis and totally
understand some of them.
Yeah.
I was stopped fucking making
yourself out to be the hero.
Oh no one of these guys.
But I'm not one of these guys,
so leave me the fuck alone with this stuff
and if this stuff will interfere with
our sex life and change the woman
that I have learned to love,
I don't know where this will leave us.
What do you think of this?
Am I being too non empathetic here?
It's been,
I don't think you're an empathetic person.
Um,
I would say that, uh, yeah, I this a wrap.
This is not the kind of
woman you're looking for. Um,
yeah.
And this is a major change
in her. All right. I mean,
I don't know what goes on between the two
of you, but if she's going to be like,
hey, watch this and we need to change
some stuff in the bedroom, like the,
the relationship as you know,
it is over and uh,
and it's long distance. I mean,
yeah, it's, it's a fucking rap.
I would walk away. Um, alright.
Fucked up at, at pet shop.
Last one here. Fucked
up at the pet shop he's
with. Did Ghost pet shop boys. That's
right. And I fucked up at pet shop.
How's it going? Oh,
Billy Bordeaux. Bullocks.
Um, love the podcast. Congrats
to the day. Thank you very much.
All the great work onF is for family
baggies to having left at anything so hard
and long time old. Billy,
I fucked up recently,
but no one knows I've done anything wrong.
I work at a pet shop,
we sell rabbits and mice,
things like that.
And my job is to feed them
and clean their cages.
I already don't like where this is going.
Not the most exciting thing in the world,
but I love animals and they
look so sad a lot of the time.
So I try to make their lives a little
better by looking after them the best I
can. That's what I would do if I worked
at a pet store. Long Story Short,
I'm fairly new.
So the first day I was taught how to
tell the male rabbits from the female
rabbits. It turns out you have
to feel for the testicles,
which wasn't that hard as a lot of the
rabbits had really big balls like holy
shit. And I was pretty confident that
I could do it in the future. God,
these are weird this week. Fast forward
to Monday, turns out I cannot do it.
We've got a whole load of new lion had
rabbits in with massive for making it
almost impossible to locate the balls.
Well just flick them between the legs.
If the rabbit turns around like what the
fuck was that for it? She has a pussy.
If you fucking flake it between the
legs and the thing collapses, you know,
and lays there for 30 seconds while
his other friends laugh at him. Uh,
that is a male. And the ones laughing.
Well, women laugh at that shit too.
Anyways, at that stage it was
just me and one of the student,
part time workers who probably had
just learned to locate his own balls,
let alone someone else's. Uh, why is
this a big deal? Well, I can tell you,
I think you can figure out,
we can,
why we can't put the males
in with the females bill.
I seriously don't know
what the fuck happened,
but I went home that evening having no
idea if I was going to arrive back into
work with double the number of rabbits.
I know that's not how gestation works,
but fuck it. Uh, what would you
do if you were in my situation?
I just started working
here and I really like it,
but I have no idea how to explain how I
fucked this up so badly. Thanks. Well,
what happened?
We've got a whole new low of new lion,
had rabbits in with massive for making
it almost impossible. So what is this,
what is the problem here?
You're worried that you're going to put
them in with the wrong ones and a calf?
Fuck. Oh my God. I just dropped
my fucking laptop and Mike Foot.
Ah, Jesus Christ. Um, I don't
know what the problem is, sir.
What I would do is I would come clean
before you have 7,000 rabbits and they got
to feed them to the snakes.
That's what I would do. All right.
How hard is it to find fucking balls?
I'd put on a glove. Then I
go, you like underneath them,
you know, dead had a boot and
a button up. I don't know.
I don't know what you're out of my year.
I'm out of my element.
I don't know what to tell you.
I don't know how to find rabbit balls.
I would definitely come clean and say
that you think you fucking messed up
because a, the fact that you're running
from this problem like that guy in Fargo.
Ah gees. I'm going to get you the
numbers like you doing that right now.
All right?
And I'm afraid you're going to end up
blaming the fucking college student.
All right? So I would just come
clean. Say that you fucked up.
I don't think they're going to fire
you over it. You know what I mean? Uh,
that's what I would do and I would
learn how to find rabbit balls.
I would get into another line of
business. All right? Okay. There you go.
That's the podcast for this week.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
If you'd like to
contribute to this podcast,
just go to a Netflix and
watchF is for family this week.
If you don't want to do that, go to
my podcast page. Click on the, uh,
go on my website.
Click on the podcast page.
And if you're going to buy something on
Amazon, just click on the Amazon link.
It takes you there.
I get credit for driving traffic and they
kicked me a little doe ray meal with a,
okay, that's it. Go fuck yourselves
and I will talk to you on Thursday.